- Um.
(gentle music)
- My vibe on the sexy Santa thing?
I think it's cool, it's
not really my thing.
- Santa's just not, not a sexy thing.
- There's some men and
women out there that are
super kinky and into some weird s***.
- It's this jolly, old man
that comes down chimneys
and gives little children presents
and then you want that
same person without a beard
laying in your bed ready to f***.
That's kinda strange.
- I don't thing that trying
on sexy Santa outfits is
gonna ruin my perception of Santa,
but it might ruin some other
people's perception of Santa.
- What do we got, oh God.
- Oh!
Alright.
This is like a Borat Santa with a hoodie.
- So that goes like that, okay.
- You gotta have the quintessential hat.
- Alright let's do this, here we go.
(lively music)
- You know I was gonna go for it.
I was gonna show the
world my little baby butt.
I'll be honest, it was just falling out
and I had to wear underwear under it.
This is not made for a male genitalia.
(laughs)
- And I didn't have the balls to wear
this ass out sorry everyone.
- This is... (laughs)
Trash is the word I'd
say I feel really trashy,
but I like that I can
show off my chest tattoo.
- The nipples being exposed,
I thought I would like.
Not actually into it,
I just don't feel sexy.
I feel a little trashy.
- I think that this could be fun for...
a couple who gets
married around Christmas.
A wife or husband wants to
surprise their wife or husband.
- It really wants me to
have a certain figure
that I'm just kind of
busting out of right now.
- If I found someone and
really cared about them,
this was their thing
I could see this being
on their birthdays and
Christmas type of thing,
I'd be glad to do for them,
but this would not be my go to.
- I love that this goes
all the way down and
leads to the treasure.
- This outfit could be higher quality.
This is really just a one
and done, one time wear.
If you're looking for real
lasting sexy Santa experience
maybe leather or latex.
- I think the market on
sexy Santa for men lingerie
has not been cornered and we
should really dive in there
and make it a thing.
Lumbersexuals are really hot right now
and you've got the dad
bod, you combine those two
and you basically have Santa
but he's good with kids
and he's married for a long time.
We never heard about him
cheating on Mrs. Clause,
so he's the ideal man.
- To all those boys and girls out there in
the magical world of YouTube
or wherever you're watching this;
Merry Christmas to you and your family.
Share this with everyone,
let them know the joy
that Santa can bring.
(gentle music)
(lively music)